dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir today I've got
some fluids for you
most hobby projects with fluid
simulations involve the simulation of a
piece of sloshing liquid in a virtual
container however if you have a more
elaborate project at hand the story is
not so simple anymore
this new paper elevates the quality and
realism of these simulations through
using mixture theory now what is there
to be mixed you ask well what mixture
Theory does for us is that it helps
simulating how liquids interact with
fabrics including splashing wringing and
more these simulations have to take into
account that the fabrics may absorb some
of the liquids poured onto them and get
saturated how diffusion transports this
liquid to nearby yarn strands
or what you see here is a simulation
with porous plastic where water flows
off of and also through this material as
well here you see how it can simulate
honey dripping down on a piece of cloth
this is a real good one if you are a
parent with small children you probably
have lots of experience with this
situation and can assess the quality of
this simulation really well the visual
fidelity of these simulations is truly
second to none I love it
now the question naturally arises how do
we know if these simulations are close
to what would happen in reality we don't
just make a simulation and accept it as
true to life if it looks good right well
of course not
the paper also contains comparisons
against real-world laboratory results to
ensure the validity of these results so
make sure to have a look at it in the
video description and if you've been
watching this series for a while you
notice that I always recommend that you
check out the papers yourself and even
though it is true that these are
technical write-ups that are meant to
communicate results between experts it
is beneficial for everyone to also read
at least a small part of it if you do
you'll not only see beautiful
craftsmanship but you'll also learn how
to make a statement and how to prove the
validity of this statement this is a
scale that is necessary to find truth so
please read your papers thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time